I remember somebody threatening me on  the street because some people did  object to the film getting made and all  that and I remember people saying that  they were going to do me harm and stuff  like that you know and I would actually  go like I don't know if it's somebody  somebody warned me must have been a  friend of mine who was crazy early on  the internet and they warned me they  called me up and they went there's some  person and they know where you walk  every single day and you go down this  back alley and they say that they're  going to jump on you and they're going  to rip your cerebral cortex out of your  head so please don't go down that alley  so of course I was like I'm going to  that alley I want to see what happens  unfortunately nothing I kept walking up  and down here going where are they come  on  nothing never happened